depuis ce samedi voilà ce que voient les
88 millions d'abonnés du compte twitter
de donald trump
quand il essaye d'aller sur sa page
suite aux évènements de mercredi dernier
et à l'envahissement du capitole la
plateforme a décidé de le bannir
définitivement en cause les deux
derniers tweets du président sortant les
géniaux 75 millions d'américains
patriotes qui ont voté pour moi america
first aimé qu'america gréng n auront une
énorme voit dans le futur ils ne seront
ni mépriser ni traité injustement de
quelques manières que ce soit à tous
ceux qui m'ont demandé je n'irai pas à
la cérémonie d'investiture le 20 janvier
le réseau social s'est expliqué sur sa
décision dans un communiqué en raison
des tensions persistantes aux états unis
et de la reprise du débat mondial à
propos des personnes qui ont pris
d'assaut le capitole le 6 janvier 2021
ces deux tweets peuvent être compris
comme une incitation à la violence par
certains publics
pour donald trump l'affront est de
taille lui qui avait fait de son compte
twitter le navire amiral de sa
communication le moyen d'être en prise
directe avec ses électeurs en court
circuitant les médias qu'ils jugent
hostile et malhonnête ni stratégie
assumée sans filtre justement sur
twitter où il diffusé en juillet 2010
est cette vidéo dans laquelle on le voit
affronter un catcheur incarnant cnm
autre mauvaise nouvelle pour donald
trump il ne pourra pas se rabattre sur
les autres réseaux sociaux facebook
instagram snapshot switch l'ont eux
aussi suspendus